(upbeat music)
- Ready for this one?
And I get to say it out loud,
I Robot, You Jane:
Machine Learning, Diversity,
and Opportunities.
So you can see, quite diverse up here.
Tons of opportunity and
I don't know, one or two AI experts.
So we're gonna get things started.
The way we're gonna do this is
once again, we're having
a panel mentality.
It's about looking at
the continuum of thought,
everybody's perspectives,
and just having a good time.
So,
I'm going to look to you, Gary.
- [Gary] Okay.
(laughs)
- [Denise] What AI
technology interests you most
moving forward in the next three years?
- What AI?
- [Denise] Or technology,
it doesn't have to
be specific to AI.
- Yeah no I get it.
I mean, I think about AI a lot.
I mean, I think what
I'm most interested in
is that
there's an enormous amount
of things that humans do
that is really dumb shit.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And so, what excites me about AI is
I think people get hyperbolized into,
'oh my God, people are going to lose jobs'
and all these things.
And for me, I think people are
going to be able to focus on
far more interesting behaviors
because things are going to be eliminated.
We were told that tractors
were going to eliminate jobs
for farmers and that this
was going to be devastating.
So for me, at its beginning,
just because I grew up as a merchant,
the amount of things that are happening
in customer service
that are being used by
enormous amount of people
that the same question is
being asked over and over,
the elimination of simple questions,
that information is at the fingertip.
Especially when layered
on top of a voice device
like an Alexa or Google Home
has me extremely excited.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna go down to this side.
- So I'm gonna touch upon.
So Alexa, Google Home and personal AI
is what I'm really excited about.
I actually invested a couple years ago
in, like an Indiegogo
type of personal robot.
I got to meet him this year,
Buddy at CES, it's really exciting.
- [Denise] So cool!
- And I've spoken to Sophia the robot,
I really look at that as
definitely the future.
Being able to interact with AI
and having them in our lives
on a daily basis
more than just Google
Home and Alexa and Siri.
But I'd like for them to become
my personal assistant,
do all the things that I don't want to do
and make my life a lot easier.
So I look really forward
to that happening.
- So Neil, who wins and who
loses with this technology?
- That's a good question.
I think, simply put,
those who are prepared and
are ready for what's coming
or at least understand
or aware of what's coming
will probably win and those that don't
unfortunately won't.
I read a report saying that just like
self driving cars or vehicles,
the net jobs lost worldwide
will be about 60 million.
Right?
And it's not just the taxi drivers,
the truck drivers losing their jobs.
It's the ecosystem around them, right?
You don't have to make as many cars,
you don't use as many suppliers,
the truck stops, the diners, the motels
that support those guys will all go away.
The question becomes,
what do we do with those people?
Some people we could probably retrain,
up-skill for those jobs of tomorrow
which is probably six to eight years out,
and some people we can't.
We can't tell someone
that's in their mid 40's
married with some kids that
'hey guess what?
'you're gonna go back to
school for six years.'
So, we need to try to figure out
what is the right thing to
try and do for these people?
- And Common, how does
this impact our kids
and future generations?
- Well, information is very important
but something that Gary
said that I thought was
something about, how I felt about AI
when I learned that AI was
helping a lot of farmers
when it comes to their
crops to really predict.
Because we've been having issues with food
and they were saying by the year 2060
the food was just gonna be all messed up.
But our farmers are getting
a lot of information
from AI which has a chance
to feed not only our kids
but feed us in a healthy way,
and I think it's important that
we just continue to educate
and give as much information about it
so that our kids,
'cause we got kids out
there that are brilliant
and now it's just about
exposing them to that.
So, I think that's how AI is helping.
I mean, and we've seen it help kids,
like I said, who have issues with sight,
kids who've had disabilities.
It's helped kids with
education, excuse me?
- [Denise] Incredible!
- Yeah it's incredible.
And it also,
they've been using it to detect
when they think kids might be
looking to drop out of school,
and hopefully come up with ideas
that will keep them in school.
So I think that's another way
it could benefit our youth
but I feel we have the ability for it
to benefit not only our youth
but us as adults too.
- I'd love to just build
on, and I just think
this is such a fascinating conversation,
on the winners and losers.
- [Denise] Yeah.
- We're now three years
into this conversation
where people realize certain
people are going to lose jobs.
It's going to be another
five to seven to nine
to 12 years when this
starts hitting scale.
I struggle, not that I'm right or wrong,
I struggle that if you're a truck driver
and you know autonomous trucks are coming,
and you have a 12 year head start
to address your vulnerability,
it's hard for me to muster up
super big fucking tears
for that guy or gal losing their job
when they have a 12
fucking year head start
that this thing is going away!
And I think that a lot of us
are having these conversations
rightfully so, 'cause we
have a lot of compassion,
that these things are going to happen.
But at some level,
there's a very interesting
line about accountability
when this is facing you.
I mean, I don't feel bad for
Toys "R" Us going out of business!
Nobody cried for the
book stores when they saw
Amazon was coming to fucking get 'em!
And so I think there's a
very important conversation
that this is gonna take a while,
but when we get to that moment,
where does accountability
in this knowledge?
- But that's why what
Gary is saying is true,
but along with that,
that's why people need to be exposed
and get the information,
so the accountability can be like,
'Yo, you knew about this.
'You knew about this, so you
could've done something.'
But everybody needs a fair shake.
It's America.
We want everybody to get a fair shake.
We know that's not what's been happening
but everybody deserves that.
- And to your point,
that's what fucking gets
me so excited about this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And my big thing is,
you could live in Instagram
Explore for nine hours
or you can get your
fucking Google game up.
- Yeah.
- You know?
I mean, that's what so
powerful about this.
- [Denise] Yes.
- Whether it's immigrants
or minorities or female,
what you think about
the scale of technology,
its ability to potentially
level the playing field
is so remarkably powerful.
- If I could just comment on that,
I think those are both
really great points,
and I think that's the question
we're struggling with as a global society.
'Cause we're reaching
an inflection point now
of we could do great things, right?
Are we gonna rise to the challenge,
learn, do more complex work,
higher value work, be more creative?
Or are we gonna go the
route of infotainment
and watch YouTube videos,
watch Game of Thrones and other things?
Right now,
I don't know which way
we'll break as a society!
- But, I'm looking at the future of work
and I think the future is like
our data is what will
allow us to earn income.
So, where
and also universal base of income,
I think about those things all the time.
If AI is taking over all the jobs
and we have to think of other ways
to earn income and of course infotainment
is definitely one of them,
but just basically
right now, I use Sweatcoin.
I earn $600 a month just by walking.
That's it.
- I could tell you all
seem a little bit bashful,
Gary you got more to that?
Go, go.
- I just think this is interesting,
I think history can help us so much.
You know, Game of Thrones
or listening to music
or watching a video of somebody.
Escapism has always been
such a foundational part of us.
The fact that the circus
was the leading fucking place that
people spent money on
during the Great Depression
blows my fucking head off!
People don't have food
and the circus is dominating.
Why?
Because life was super hard
and getting those two or three hours.
I'm sure when I listen to an album,
that's escapism, that's for me to balance.
It's a very interesting human trait
that we are thinking about
and I just think it's a remarkable time.
- So just to kind of bring this together
to balance the two of you
and bring this panel together.
When we're going to the
humanism view of this,
once we've equaled the playing field,
if you're not moving forward,
you're moving backwards.
We're all accountable for
it, whatever we do next.
- [Common] True.
- [Denise] Alright.
- Guys I wanna go off script,
so I wanna kinda play on what you guys
were talking about and bring you guys in
and y'all seem very
comfortable, so bear with me.
(laughs)
- [Common] Okay.
- There's this common misconception
when we talk about artificial
intelligence, right?
It's an amalgamation of technologies.
Computer vision, NLP, voice recognition,
data processing in the
cloud, storage in the cloud,
many, many other things, robotics.
And this idea that it's
going to be part of this
fourth industrial revolution
but we're gonna disintermediate everything
and put everybody out of work
is often misconceived.
Right?
Because some people would say
that the jobs are going to go to first
are the highest paid,
repetitive and highly objective jobs.
Arguably, radiologists are more at risk
than a truck driver.
So, I wanna kind of go through that
and ask your opinion on what jobs
you actually think changed
and what sort of opportunities
that opened up for us?
Common, you okay if I start with you?
- Well yeah, you could start with me.
I know one thing that
a job you won't lose.
If you're a good artist,
(laughs, applauding)
- That's facts!
- One job you would not
lose if you're an artist.
And then I mean, I also think
as Gary was alluding to,
certain forms of entertainment
and things that we enjoy,
you're just not gonna lose that job.
I mean, I still wanna see Lebron James,
simple as that.
- [Shahi] You can't replace that.
- You can't replace that and
you can't replace Frank Ocean.
- [Shahi] You can't replace Common.
- Yeah that's right,
that's right.
(laughs, applauding)
I know they've got, what do they got?
You know the thing they did
with Tupac and all those.
- Holograms.
- Holograms, but
it's nothing like having the real thing.
- Alright man, thank you.
Gary, let's bring it your way
and I'll walk it down, guys.
- Look, I think you nailed it.
Anything that's repetitive
and done on the back of technology
is going to be fundamentally vulnerable.
So, you know, it's funny.
Same thing with the internet,
I remember when the internet
started becoming real and
people actually had AOL,
I remember thinking with Amazon,
hey bookstores, it's your turn, right?
And then Uber came along and it was
taxi cabs, it's your turn.
You know, to me,
everybody is gonna have a turn
outside of, that is black and white.
I think what Common is referring to
which is so powerful about art
is that it's gray.
Right?
- [Common] Yes.
But I think anything
that is black and white
is remarkably vulnerable.
There's so many things that are done
by people typing away at a computer.
A human typing away at a computer
to create an action for another human
is 100 percent vulnerable.
- [Shahi] Phu, what about you?
- I look at this as an opportunity
for all of us to become Polymass,
Renaissance men and women,
the day of being specialized in a skill.
That's not happening anymore, you know?
Right?
(audience members cheer)
So Common you're an artist,
but now you're also doing tech stuff,
I used to do so many different
things before I did this.
I was a behavioral therapist,
I had a VR company, an AR company,
a launching company.
I'm a VC, so many things.
I look at this as a
real opportunity for us
to learn so many different things
and let the AI take all
the repetitive jobs.
They should!
I don't think there should
be anymore slave labor!
This is an opportunity.
Like I was just in
China for the last month
and there's no recycling where I was
because they have humans to
separate all the recycling.
Well, for those people to really thrive,
they could start thinking
about more things
than just surviving that
the AI can take over.
And because of that little smartphone
they can all look at becoming
infotainers themselves
and earn on their
entertainment and their data.
That's really exciting.
- I agree that's great.
So Neil, I want to close
with you on this one.
You're very modest, but
you are a master inventor,
you are a master prognosticator.
What do you see happening here?
- I want to start by just
trying to sum it up that
machines are about productivity
and people are about creativity.
There are things that machines
do better than people,
there are things people do
much better than machines.
And we have to get to that line.
And I think what's going on today
is people are surprised
by some of the things
that machines are good at.
People say, well, okay,
driving a taxi or a bus, that's one thing.
But how could an AI do
something a lawyer could do?
If you think about some of the tasks that
lawyers do coming out of law school,
they're very productive types of tasks.
And the goal is not to
'we're gonna replace all
those guys with that',
but we're gonna free their time up
to do more complex work,
more creative type of work.
Maybe that's case strategy,
maybe that's more engagement
and understanding the
client or what's going on.
I think what we really have
to do deal with, again,
as a society is
understanding how our work,
how our lives are going
to be transformed by this.
What can we do that's
more, that's more creative?
And I don't think this is
a unique challenge for us.
You know, technology
has always been there,
reshaping our lives.
I think it's the change is
coming faster and faster.
And I think that's what
people are struggling with
is the stuff we're talking about
is not 20 years away.
In some cases it's not
even five years away,
it's already here.
What do we do?
- So this shift that we're talking about
opens up a subject.
And this is a unique panel.
'Cause we can go from deep tech
to diversity and culture.
And so I wanna hand this one off to Denise
'cause obviously this
queues you up beautifully
for the next question on what this means.
- Absolutely.
So at the end of the day, guys,
the tech industry is taking a lot of fire
for not being diverse,
especially at the top echelons.
So,
why is diversity important?
What does it mean to the future?
And what opportunities does it bring?
- [Phu] Can I start with this?
- Yes.
- This is something that
I'm super passionate about.
I started the Women in
Blockchain Foundation
to address this specifically.
I was tired of being the only woman
at the table in every tech company
at every meeting.
And, yes women, join!
Join the Blockchain!
- [Denise] Yes, yes!
(applauding)
WomenInBlockchainFoundation.org
Join our telegram channel.
(laughs)
But it's really important
for us to be diverse
'cause if you think about
it on a technological layer,
like a blockchain having
nodes all around the world,
in every corner of the universe.
Well, if it's in every
corner of the universe,
it's gonna take everyone
in every corner of the universe
to be put in this.
And that has to be more than
just a White guy in his mom's basement.
(laughs)
I love White guys but
it has to be every single one of us
and if we're talking about
a new era of wealth creation
it has to include all of us.
'Cause in the dot com
era, it was mainly men.
It's like 90 percent men
were able to gain from this.
Well here's an opportunity.
I, myself, have been
able to gain from this
and I want everyone else to come with me
and join this revolution.
That's what I'm so passionate about.
So yes, diversity is very important,
everyone needs to come on
board and educate yourselves.
Do whatever it takes,
look at every YouTube channel,
follow Gary and everything he's teaching,
(laughs)
listen to music.
There's so much out there.
Just do what it takes and
get everyone to join you.
- [Shahi] Well said Phu, well said.
- And you know,
this is the world, man.
Everybody has something to offer.
We just all have something
to give to this world
and Jeff brought up something
when I was talking back there.
A community that I didn't acknowledge
was the Native American, the First Nation
brothers and sisters
who I saw at one point actually
getting in tune with
some AI technology too,
through something I was
doing with Microsoft.
And it was like, man,
so many gifts have been given to the world
from different cultures,
and from women and men and
from people from Africa
to India to the United States.
And they come from so many
different backgrounds.
So it's important that we
get to use our technology
and have diversity but it's also
one of the things that's important
that we educate first
so the people that we're asking to
step up into these jobs
are prepared and have what Gary said
the accountability to do it.
But then we also have to
recognize some of these companies.
The people, the higher ups
have to be diverse too.
We have to have diverse
people in the boardrooms
making decisions or it's just
basically like what we've been seeing
in our country for so many years.
Yeah we're gonna make it diverse,
we gonna bring more people of color in
but are they making any decisions,
are they getting any opportunities
to be a part of some of
the significant changes
that's coming from up top?
And that's where I think
diversity is gonna have to start.
From the education and up in the top.
There's so many levels to get
to diversity, to be honest.
- [Denise] Yes, yes.
(clapping)
- I think this
- You come from a
family of immigrants, right?
- Yeah I was born in Belarus
in the former Soviet Union.
To me, it's a very important subject
because take out
first of all, it's human.
If you're not a human that believes in it,
you're unbelievably vulnerable and
unbelievably in a
defensive, negative place.
But take that away.
Let's just make it raw about business
and make it about what
people tend to make it about.
Perspective and context
are strengths, not weaknesses.
It's almost like, what
if we talked about food?
You know how shitty it would be
to just eat Italian food?
And Italian food is fucking rad,
but it would make no sense.
And so for me,
I'm fascinated by companies that
all look the same,
all the decision makers look the same.
To me very honestly,
especially in the environment
we now live in today
and I don't mean the
political environment,
I mean just where the
evolution of technology
and opportunities are,
it's a vulnerability.
It's laughable to not take context
from all walks of life
from different angles.
I'll tell you one that I'm unbelievably
fascinated about that is
not talked enough about in technology.
Thank God we're talking so
much about brown and black
and minorities and females,
but we don't talk about ageism at all!
- [Group] Mmm.
- You know, I'm unbelievably a big fan
of people in their 60's,
70's, 80's and 90's
'cause I think they have deep
context for fucking life.
But people that are 70 and above
are completely getting
shit on in our ecosystem.
And so, I've been thinking a lot about
starting an incubator that is actually
incubated out of a retirement home.
- [Denise] I love it!
Yes!
(applauding)
- So I've always thought,
you know I came from
a whole lot of little
and so I always thought I had an advantage
because I think adversity is an advantage.
So I think in general,
why is it important?
Because you'll do better shit
if you have a diverse team.
- We're so interconnected now.
If we're not representing the
entire stakeholder
environment at the very top.
- You're vulnerable,
you're fucking vulnerable.
- We're screwed!
Exactly, that's it, that's it.
- Well in addition to
that, I just wanted to add
I'm also concerned about
who's programming this AI?
If it's not from a diverse kind of people
who are doing the programming,
we're not gonna get the protocols
that are needed to represent what we want.
- [Denise] It's one dimensional.
- This is way more
important than people think,
I'll give you the comp in real life.
Everything for a long time
was just made for righties.
What about fucking lefties?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right?
And so people may hear that
and they may not
understand but if you're a,
who's a lefty out there?
Shits fucked up, right?
(laughs)
And so, I think it's an important issue.
- Neil, we don't want to leave
you out of this conversation.
- 100 percent agree with everybody
and Phu actually brought
up a really critical point.
'Cause you've already seen
with so many iSolutions
there is inadvertent bias in the training.
- [Gary] 100 percent.
- You look at Google Vision.
I know those guys didn't mean to do it
but it was really good
at recognizing white men
and not so much everybody else
because it was built and
trained by white men.
And I think as we're moving forward
as we become more integrated in our lives
and it's gonna start doing more
to assist us with decision making.
Making sure that training
is as bias-free as possible,
has the multi-perspective
is gonna be critical.
I can tell you that in my
work with the United Nations,
in the span of about six months,
a lot of the leaders went from this is a
type of thing to
we need robot judges.
Robot judges are going to
reduce bias in the court system,
help more people, that kind of stuff.
But it all boils down to that training.
And without the right diversity,
we're gonna keep making
those same mistakes.
- You guys,
(applauding)
I cannot tell you what an
important topic this is,
so thank you.
It's near and dear to my heart.
- Guys, wanna shift
gears just a little bit
and take a time trip back with me.
Everybody on this stage
is a product of the
third digital revolution.
We grew up with micro-electronics
through evolution,
digital information technology,
information systems.
It's foundationally
changed everybody here.
You roll the clock back 40, 50 years,
we had just landed on the moon.
The idea of private rockets was ridiculous
unless you were building
them in your back yard.
There were no microwave ovens,
there were no smartphones,
there were no cell phones.
The internet as we knew
it wasn't invented,
in fact it's predecessor
ARPANET only started in 1983.
Stem cells,
nobody even knew what the
genome was at that time.
So I want you to put your
thinking hats on and tell me
as we move to the precipice of this
fourth digital revolution,
we are seeing unprecedented technology.
We have quantum computing coming
which changes everything.
Possibly nuclear fusion as a power source.
We now have robotics,
artificial intelligence,
machine learning and
more computational power
on a phone that Gary
pulled out of his pocket
that are used to run Universities.
- That's right.
- So, play it forward to 2050.
Neil I'm gonna start at this side with you
'cause this is your job.
This is where you live.
- [Denise] This is what
you do for a living.
Plus we've got the same haircut
(laughs)
this was planned by the way.
So tell me and tell this crowd
what you think we can expect.
- I will tell you we're moving so fast
it's really difficult.
If I were to wind the
clock back just 10 years
who would've predicted
something like Uber?
- [Gary] Never.
- Right?
I think if we're looking at
2050 what's gonna happen,
I'm gonna throw it out
there and say one word.
Cyborgs.
(applauding)
Not about personal assistants
or anything.
We're already seeing a big move towards
human computer integration.
They've already done experimental surgery
that could put digital cameras
in a blind persons' eyes
and transmit the image so they can see.
I think 2050 will be cyborgs.
- [Shahi] Phu.
- I'm already into that now.
(laughs)
I look at us being able to have
not only cyborgs here on Earth
but doing stuff on other planets.
I already started my own embryo portfolio
so that I could have
my own progeny in Mars
when we start doing that.
I think that's the future.
One concern is that when the cyborgs come
there'll be less human interaction.
Like I won't need a man anymore
'cause I'll have my own
sex robot, you know?
(laughs)
- [Denise] Sign me up.
- [Gary] Sex robots are gonna be
fuckin' amazing.
- I love men,
they'll always be
(laughs)
Just kidding, just jokes,
just joking.
But I think there will
be a lot of training
needed for us to interact with humans.
So that job will be available.
(laughs)
- Gary, your thoughts?
- I think sex robots are
going to be fucking amazing.
(laughing)
Nobody's gonna leave their fucking home.
(laughs)
So I'm not super passionate about the
Nostradamus business.
You know?
There's a lot of things
that we're gonna be
close on and there's gonna be
a billion things that we
could never even think about.
For me what stands out is,
what I'm fascinated by technology is
I think it's throwing us back.
If you ask me the best indicator of
where we'll be in 2050,
I think things that we were doing
in the 17 and 1800's play out.
Let me give you an example.
- [Audience Member] Yeah!
(laughs)
- [Common] That's somebody
- [Shahi] Preachin', Gary!
- Let me give you the one
that really stands out for me.
What social media has done
is it's allowed us to know
much more about each other
than we ever could before at scale,
which was far more similar
to what was happening
in the old days when
your little community was your whole world
and you did know
everything about everybody.
100 percent.
I think one of the more interesting things
to think about in 2050 or maybe 2100
is I think things that
we've put on pedestal,
religions, marriages,
are gonna become
dramatically more vulnerable.
I think that the shadows of our society
are being exposed by technology,
there's no where to hide
and I think most of the institutions
that we hold near and dear
are actually built up by
the shadows of our society.
And so I think this gets a
hell of a lot more emotional
than people think.
I actually hope that we become
a hell of a lot less hypocritical
once we realize that we
all have fucking skeletons
and we all have massive flaws
which will then allow us
to have 100 years of pain
which will then lead to
100 years of nirvana.
- Yeah.
- Whoo!
I like that idea.
(applauding)
- I like that.
- So Common,
you wanna bring this one home for me?
You have been absolutely everywhere.
- I mean, look.
You're asking the person that probably
least has the ideas of
where we'll be in 2050.
I am a person that likes
to stay in the present
(laughs)
but if I do think of
I have an album called Be
and that was about being in the present,
just being present.
But if I do have to think about the future
and what I would like to
see AI technology bring is
maybe we'll have a cure for cancer through
technology.
(applauding)
And as we talked about earlier
maybe it'll be healthier foods
being put in neighborhoods
that don't get healthy foods
because of technology and maybe
we could even use technology
to advance rehabilitation
as I talked about in prisons.
I'm just talking about
dreams I got, right?
Maybe technology will help
bring us together more
as people and love will
be the center of it
and technology will just be a tool of it.
- [Gary] Believe that.
- So those are the things that I dream of
in my dream world 'cause I'm a dreamer.
But right now I'm gonna
stay in the present,
I'm grateful to be here
with you brilliant people.
- Beautiful man, thank you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you guys.
This has been an insane panel.
We could talk all night, I think.
I think we could all agree to that,
but all good things
have to come to an end.
And a huge round of
applause for our guests!
(applauding)